[Music]
imagine a version of earth where mass
extinction events occur like clockwork
where every 50 million years solar
storms wipe out the majority of life and
the survivors must start again
from such a relentless cycle of
destruction and renewal what sorts of
species might rise to the challenge
nijin konai is a speculative biology
project set on a planet where periods of
intense solar radiation constantly reset
the timeline on evolution as a result
the life forms that now populate this
world are true survivors the product of
countless generations of mass extinction
and rebirth
brought to life by the talented artist
and creator lorenzo battilani the world
is rich in biological detail indeed this
might be one of the most ambitious
speculative biology projects i've ever
covered comprising hundreds of species
with thousands of details about each one
the first volume the artist is creating
focuses on the aquatic life so for this
entry into the archive we'll explore the
seas of this incredible world so let's
submerge ourselves in the waters of
nijin konai staying alert to what lurks
in the depths as we discover a world
beneath the waves
the ozone layer of nijin konai's
atmosphere is extremely thin leaving the
planet at the mercy of solar radiation
surges in between the surges life
rebounds just 32 million years after the
most recent mass extinction the latest
inheritors of nijian konai have already
achieved incredible diversity throughout
the oceans
in the midwater currents swims the
ubiquitous spotted snakejetter a
creature that possesses a surprising
adaptation they ingest their food whole
storing their meals in an enlargeable
sack
like the gulper eels of earth this sack
can swell up to a size as big as the
animal itself depending on the size of
their most recent mouthful the spotted
snakejetter is a quintessential example
of the fish-like precionadia one of the
main lineages that have risen to
prominence in the current era yet the
uniqueness of the snakejetter shows that
on nijin konai even commonplace
lifeforms can be remarkable
deeper in the open sea other life forms
have found radically different niches to
fill the purple pillow head inhabits low
current environments and has a peculiar
method of getting food unlike the
snakejetter this midsize life form is a
filter feeder possessing 10
forward-facing filtration organs in the
front section of their cranium they
spend their days filtering particulates
from the current a feeding behavior
similar to earth whale sharks the taxon
they represent is composed primarily of
filter feeders which are finding great
success on the nutrient-rich currents of
nijin konai's oceans in looking at such
vibrant forms of life there's a strange
comfort that these populations are the
remainders of a mass extinction
in the reef-like environments of warmer
waters surreal forms of life seek refuge
the butterfly chi-chi is one such
species a rather tiny organism their
trunk-like appendage gives them an
unmistakable look the butterfly chichi
uses their miniature trunk to bring
small pieces of vegetation into their
mouths and though you'd never know it by
looking at them this species is the last
herbivore of a great line once part of
an incredibly successful order of
megafauna the latest extinction has left
the butterfly chichi all alone yet upon
the reefs they have endured and will
continue to carry their taxon's legacy
into the future
in the thick vegetation of the denser
reefs a long eel-like life-form
undulates through the water this is a
rainbow rockhead and while they might
look threatening they aren't carnivores
indeed this filter feeder is rather shy
preferring to remain out of sight like
the moray eel the rainbow rockhead makes
their home in the cracks and crevices of
the reef and spend most of their time
hidden from view yet a glimpse of a
rainbow rockhead is a stunning one as
they possess vibrant colors to attract
mates while life on nigerian konai may
be one of inevitable struggle beauty
still finds a way to emerge
yet all environments have their
predators the double jaw kugawa is a
lonesome hunter that will sometimes come
to the reefs in search of food
possessing a unique jaw apparatus for
ensnaring prey the kugawa can hunt a
variety of species across the ocean
while typically solitary once a year the
kugawa group together with others of
their kind in a school of unparalleled
volume in our oceans schools of fish can
reach amazing sizes with some stretching
for several miles yet during their
migration to the tropics of the north
the kugawa school comprises the species
entire mature global population a site
that would be as alarming as it would be
stunning
and there is a giant upon the reef this
is a sand maker and they have one of the
largest head to body ratios on the
planet evolved to feed on the shelled
plants that make up the reefs they
inhabit they act as a key contributor to
the bio-erosion processes of the ocean
each time they feed they grind shells
into a fine sand creating new sediment
that helps the reefs expand freshwater
mollusks like lithureto at bantanica
play a similar role in underwater
erosion on our planet grinding up
limestone into a fine grain sand
although at over 20 feet or 6 meters in
length the sand maker is a considerably
larger terraforming unit than an earth
mollusk sizeable though they are the
sand makers are gentle creatures and one
of the more notable herbivores on nijin
konai
across the oceans one of the more
variable clades are the frisbee fish
radiating out from a common ancestor
that evolved a tall and flattened body
to better maneuver a densely vegetated
area the many types of frisbee fish have
returned to the open ocean and are
regaining more hydrodynamic shapes many
of these emergent lineages look quite
distinctive like the heart fish a
species that true to their name mates
for life when a heartfish couple bonds
the two court each other by swirling
around mid water it's a rather poignant
form of courtship and can be seen among
other types of frisbee fish as well
this is the nazir frisbee fish these
hypnotic six-slimmed oddities have
evolved to feed on floating fronds which
might explain the design of their
unusual fins on our planet certain
genera of seahorses and their relatives
have evolved frond-like protuberances to
blend in among the plants they feed on
so it's likely the azer frisbee fish's
strange fins help break up their
silhouette amongst alien foliage in any
case the frisbee fish genus seems to be
thriving as this species can now be
found across three quarters of the
planet's oceans
yet aquatic life on nijian konai isn't
limited to just the oceans along the
banks of coastal rivers a peculiar
customer is hiding in plain sight this
is a freshwater pebble bug and they are
experts at looking like well pebbles
when other organisms get close the
pebble bug will quickly dig into the
sediment to hide leaving only their
shells exposed the unusual looking
scorpion fish of our oceans have
converged on a similar behavior to
conceal themselves in aquatic sediment
with only their shells sticking out the
pebble bugs look like any other rock yet
the pebble bug isn't just designed to
hide from predators but also to lure in
prey they possess an appendage that
greatly resembles a plant to attract
small herbivorous animals which the
pebble bug will then ambush and feed on
in a world this competitive even the
gentlest looking species can be
dangerous
back in the ocean a relative of the
pebble bug swims close to the sea floor
this is a grappling shield back and like
the pebble bug they have a thick shell
too heavy for fast swimming the shield
back relies on their natural armor to
keep them safe from the jaws of larger
predators like the sea turtles of earth
the shield back must trust that their
shells are tougher than the teeth of
most animals that swim under the waves
yet unlike the sea turtle the grappling
shield back is a predator themselves
using their prehensile appendage to stir
up sand and ensnare fleeing bottom
feeders it might seem strange that both
the shield back and the pebble bug are
hunters but both species are members of
the entodontia a once highly successful
order of mighty predators that have been
reduced to minor players following the
most recent extinction in the world of
nijin konai few species stay on top for
long
yet some antodontia have managed to
remain at the top of the food web in the
open sea the four jawed irobian ripper
hunts on the current with a name like
that you know a creature means business
unlike their relatives the ripper
possesses multiple vertically arranged
jaws that they use to latch onto prey
this unusual jaw structure might seem
overly elaborate but many types of earth
crustaceans possess similarly complex
mouth parts for ensnaring food the
ripper's extravagant mouth is actually a
sign of their primordial origins as the
ripper is the rare life form that has
changed little over the past age to have
endured so long with minimal changes the
ripper's strategy must be successful
on the subject of successful hunters
peering up from the sandy sea floor is
the phantom sea twin fish resembling a
fish flattened out by a rolling pin the
twin fish is an ambush predator that
appears a bit squashed yet by lying
flush with the sea floor the twin fish
is in the perfect position to feed on
other bottom dwellers it's a strategy
convergent with that of the spotted
wobbagong a real name for a real shark
species that lives on the sea floor and
lets prey come to them they are not the
most glamorous species next to the sleek
pursuit predators that are their cousins
but the spotted wobbegong is one shark
that knows being fast isn't the only way
to score a meal likewise the phantom sea
twin fish is rather slow but as one of
the only species in their niche there's
not much competition indeed the entire
genus was formed through an error in
gene expression some 20 million years
ago which helps make sense of the twin
fish's odd appearance
elsewhere on the seafloor a seemingly
terrifying life form skulks
this serpentine predator is a southern
sand lurker a creature that would be
horrifying if they were more than a few
centimeters in length the sand lurker
still stands out however thanks to their
unusual evolutionary history like sea
snakes the southern sand lurker is an
aquatic descendant of a land-dwelling
predecessor which made the transition
quite recently as a result the sand
lurker still possesses tiny limbs which
they use to pedal through the water and
snatch up their prey the result is a
creature that looks a bit uncanny
and disturbingly there is another
offshoot of the sand lurker this photo
shows an exceedingly rare tooth
collector a sand lurker that picks up
shed teeth from the sea floor to ingest
for calcium intake not only is this
behavior off-putting the tooth collector
seems larger than their southern cousins
a rather unsettling discovery
much further to the north the arctic
regions of nijin konai are a land of ice
and wind yet here too life has found a
way to thrive this is an arctic windmill
worm a creature that can only be found
thousands of meters below the ice living
in large colonies upon the seabed
windmill worms are one of the more
extreme creatures to emerge upon this
planet believe it or not arctic worms
also swim under earth's polar ice caps
prospering in the pitch black despite
the glacial temperatures likewise the
windmill worm is right at home in their
environment able to feed thanks to
filters on their four-part mouth these
distinctive structures actually rotate
in the arctic current like a windmill
allowing the worms to catch more food
and even direct currents towards other
members of the colony a truly ingenious
product of adaptation
elsewhere under the ice a hunter with a
curious swimming posture is waiting for
prey this is a dusky trap tongue and
they eek out a peculiar existence indeed
swimming with their mouth positioned
upwards the trap tongue spends much of
their time waiting for prey to pass
overhead their posture resembles the
amusing looking pipefish which like the
dusky trap tongue have a highly unusual
vertical swimming position you or i
might become uncomfortable with our
necks permanently craned upwards but the
trap tongue is quite literally born for
this having evolved a large stabilizing
fin and vertical counter shading that
helps them remain camouflaged while in
their strange hunting position at least
this oddity won't be uncomfortable
few undersea environments are more
extreme than the polar regions yet in
the crushing depths of the planet's
trenches conditions are even more
hostile in the twilight zone of the
abyss the crimson knife fish flashes a
fanged smile this deep sea predator
lives near volcanic fault lines and
snatches up fish that come to feed on
the chemical soup the structure on the
front of its head resembles the lure of
certain members of the anglerfish family
the knifefish's structure isn't a lure
however but a deadly weapon made of
hardened bone the knife fish uses this
horn as a biological blade impaling
fast-moving prey with pinpoint accuracy
in the deep sea staying alive is a
constant battle
a titanic predator inhabits the deep
abyssal plains of the cold trenches the
grim walker instead of swimming this
creature has evolved to walk on the
ocean floor using their six lower fins
in apex predator the grim walker hunts
using their large mouths to suck and
prey grinding them alive with their
secondary rows of teeth on earth the
worty frog fish is an aquatic organism
that also walks on the sea floor and
they have a similarly horrific appetite
able to vacuum up prey almost twice
their size
the ghostly white eyes of the grim
walker betray their poor vision as they
seek out food in the dark abyss using
echolocation alone and since the largest
grim walkers can reach almost 30 feet or
9 meters in length they're a serious
threat known to swallow diving equipment
like camera drones and even attack small
submersibles when hungry for this reason
the grim walkers are best observed from
a distance
speaking of which in the dark recess of
nijin konai a disturbing presence haunts
the void little understood giant ghost
faces are known to be swift and silent
grabbing unaware prey with their four
long arms in the few images of this
seldom glimpse life form their
appearance is like something from a bad
dream perhaps some regions of nijian
konai are better left unexamined
but let's end with a moment of beauty in
the calm blue of the open ocean one
final life form is waiting this is a
painted krillnet one of the largest
species that swim beneath the waves a
leviathan of the deep the painted
krillnet grows to vast sizes on a diet
of phytoplankton which they harvest
through the specialized hair-like
filaments on their frontal jaws like a
baleen whale the krillnet can consume
several tons of these organisms every
day as a result of their rich diet the
painted krillnet possesses a vivid
coloration which plays an important role
in their mating rituals the emergence of
organisms this massive and complex in
just a few million years proves one last
time how quickly life can fill a void
following a mass extinction
in the end the story of nijin konai is
more than one of extinction not only has
life on this planet recovered in
spectacular fashion but the world itself
is far more detailed than i could ever
cover in this video a larger science
fiction story involving human settlers
is emerging through the author's art
which you can explore more of in the
links in the description if you enjoyed
this glimpse into the larger world of
nishin konai please consider following
and supporting the artist
and as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support and like subscribe and hit
the notification icon to stay up to date
on all things curious see you in the
next video
you